ich bin da skeptisch noch nie war eine
bundestagswahl so volatil noch nie waren
so viele menschen wechselwähler noch nie
waren so viele menschen bereit auch in
letzter minute vielleicht doch mal von
der einen zur anderen seite ich bin
eigentlich ist das eine gute nachricht
sei vital unsere demokratie ist dass es
auch so spannend ist es gibt aber eine
mediale entscheidung die muss den
angepasst werden aus meiner sicht und
das ist die frage wie werden die
abschließenden fernsehduelle trelle
organisiert im frühjahr da waren die
grünen bei 23 bis 27 einmal sogar 28
prozent in den umfragen
frau berg hätte wirklich die option
gehabt hätte es ist nicht so radikal
vermasselt und da war auch richtig dass
die großen fernsehsender gesagt haben
das gibt kein duell in diesen wir machen
ein trio wirklich drei personen ernst
zur wahl stand jetzt wo es auf der
zielgerade wirklich darauf ankommt und
die kollektive willensbildung des landes
jetzt ist sind die grünen aus dem rennen
niemand glaubt mehr ernsthaft dass weder
kanzlerin werden kann einfach weil die
der abstand in den umfragen so gewaltig
geworden ist deswegen wahrheit ein duell
haben und deswegen bin ich der meinung
und ich würde das auch als geradezu als
aufruf auch an die sendeleitung von ard
und zdf platzieren wollen
lasst uns das format anpassen es gibt
keine politische situation und auch
keine legitimation für anträge die
grünen sind die kleinste fraktion im
deutschen bundestag das ist sozusagen
der faktor dinge und bei umfragen
müssten wir uns entweder für ein
quartett entscheiden wurde ein christen
mitdiskutiert könnte man sagen die vier
parteien der republikanischen mitte
verhandeln wie es weitergeht oder man
sagt okay die beiden alten volksparteien
sind jetzt wieder vorne es gibt
klassischerweise ein duell alles andere
hätte ich für wahlkampf verzerrung dann
machen auch ard und zdf müssen sich dem
vorwurf aussetzen dass wir für rot-grün
tendenziöse berichterstattung machen
weil dann immer zwei gegen einer steht
und das bildet die wirklichkeit immer
also schluss mit dem 3
klare worte ich glaube in dem punkt
folgen ihnen dass sie sagen die
öffentlich rechtlichen sender müssen
sich umstellen das haben sie aber schon
getan denn sie haben ja zum allerersten
mal auf den weg gebracht was ja das
erste mal in einem bundestagswahlkampf
war ich befürchte die
öffentlich-rechtlichen oder auch die
anderen großen fernsehanstalten sind
vermutlich etwas zu langsam für die
realität des wahlkampfes in diesem jahr
und das dürfte das problem sein ich
glaube es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen
wir organisieren ein duell antritt oder
mit vier personen an quartal was das
dann immer sein mag und
dann auf einmal passt man sich den
umfragewerten an die ja zum teil auch
nicht immer nachhaltig sind also wenn
man dann sachsen-anhalt denkt darüber
nach die union glaube ich sieben
prozentpunkte bei den letzten umfragen
zurück hinter dem was dann tatsächlich
das ergebnis war also etwas was sollte
denn eigentlich der maßstab sein und
insofern würde ich dann sagen überhaupt
keine duelle tree elle oder quartale
mehr sondern wirklich alle parteien die
beispielsweise im bundestag sitzen
einladen mit einem vertreter und eine
ganz große runde auf den weg bringen das
wäre wahrscheinlich das gerechteste also
am unterhaltsamsten wäre es doch würden
wir christian lindner noch dazu einladen
die argumentation kann ich verstehen
dass man sagt wir bilden das alles
abgeladen christian enten dazu mal hören
was er zu sagen hat ich halte es für
ganz gefährlich wir sagen na schauen wir
mal die umfragewerte auch mensch ist er
wieder ausgeladen nächste woche sage sie
dürfen doch kommen überraschung schauen
wieder gut für sie aus nehmen sie platz
sie dürfen ist doch normal ich glaube
dann auch ist zuschauer möchte ich
irgendwie auch so eine gewisse
planbarkeit haben mit dem was sich da zu
sehen bekomme und da kann ich mir gut
vorstellen weil ich total offen dass wir
sagen soll wir setzen den winter jetzt
noch von der fdp dahin und dann glaube
ich kann auch viel mehr und ich würde
auch interessieren wie dann auch eine
debatte wie argumentiert wird weil ich
glaube dass das vielleicht noch sehr
viel informativer für die wählerinnen
und wähler sein könnte als wenn man
versucht eine debatte herbeizuzaubern
die es vielleicht manchmal sogar nicht
genau gibt aber ganz abbildet knallen
und reel schließt sich ja aus wenn man
jedenfalls den maßstab des ersten teils
das ja wirklich also sagen wir
vielleicht für fernsehquoten deshalb so
gut weil leute die eingeschlagen sind
nicht umschalten also es ist sozusagen
das war ja wirklich da ein der
einschläferung versuch von drei
politikern die nur keinen fehler machen
wollen den sie hinterher wieder abräumen
müssen insofern bin ich nicht sicher ob
das quartett das löst selbst wenn
lindner den linden unterstellt dass er
ein brillanter rhetoriker ist ich frag
mich ob man nicht vielmehr auf das duell
setzen müsste man könnte dann ja auch
zwei duelle machen also zb gelb gegen
grün sie liegen weit auseinander in
wesentlichen punkten und die beiden
ehemaligen das war schon ganz schön
hinter 40 ehemaligen volksparteien
gegen
die grünen zusagen für sich in anspruch
nehmen sie das sind und dann würde mir
gut gefallen wenn man sich schon dreimal
treffen muss dass man es thematisch
macht also ich finde in diesem
gesprächsformat ist ja wirklich das
erkenntnisinteresse wonach ich meine
wahlentscheidung außerdem groß in seiner
talkshow geht es rund muss man auch
quasi entertainment dinge bedienen damit
die zuschauer aber hier geht es ja
wirklich darum herauszufinden wen möchte
ich wählen und deshalb fände ich duelle
mit
themenspezifischer festlegung heute geht
es um migration heute geht es beim
nächsten mal geht es um klima beim
nächsten mal geht es um vielleicht dann
auch ganz neue wohnen und dann aber
richtig rein in die debatte wie stellt
sich lindner das denn wirklich vor wo
kommt denn das geld wirklich her das ist
doch alles so zu sagen jetzt machen wir
uns an der stelle wirklich mal ehrlich
das wäre doch etwas was den politischen
diskurs voranbringen würde wobei man
argumente für vollkommen richtig aber
wenn ich jetzt die wahl hätte zwischen
einem diner duell serie oder dem
quartett bin ich fürs quartett und zwar
weil die koalitionsfrage so wichtig ist
jetzt in diesen drei wochen dies bei
dieser war ja auch so irre wie noch nie
sagen sie doch eh nicht mit wem sie
koalieren wollen ja schon wer mit wem
flottes bewegung gibt wo man dinge nicht
aussagen mögen sich aus nrw so das kann
man vielleicht sagen
aber eigentlich sagen weil ich kann den
satz auch schon nicht mehr hören wir
müssen sehen wo wir die meisten unserer
themen durchsetzen können wir müssen den
wählerwillen gestalten das ist doch
alles
gestimmt am ende aber es trägt er zur
frustration bei weil als erfahrener
wähler weiß ich ja dass ist am schluss
nicht der wählerwille da rauskommt ich
darf nur an diese letzte
regierungsbildung erinnern was die
menschen des vor vier jahren wirklich
nicht haben wollten war eine große
koalition das wollen sie also wenn wenn
uns die politiker noch einmal erzählen
dass sie den wählerwillen abgebildet
haben mit der kleinstmöglichen großen
koalition aller zeit na ja da lache ich
mich doch kaputt war politikum situation
ja ich finde
langen fernsehabend oder fernsehwoche
einbrocken
[Musik]